there was a time when it felt like all
American Hollywood dreamboat Chris
O'Donnell was everywhere having made a
name for himself in the 90s and hit
movies like fried green tomatoes and
scent of a woman since 2009 the actor
has appeared as G Callen in the CBS
drama NCIS Los Angeles but blockbuster
roles appear to be in short supply so
why won't Hollywood cast Chris McDonald
anymore
Batman and Robin sucked for many actors
landing a role in a superhero movie is a
major career boost which appeared to be
the case when O'Donnell took his first
turn as the Caped Crusader's sidekick in
the bad but bearable Batman Forever
unfortunately the film's follow up
Batman and Robin was an infamous dud
that put the Batman franchise on ice si
cool bro boy the film put an end to the
quartet of films in Batman's next
live-action outing didn't come until
Christian Bale's raspy dark detective'
appeared nearly a decade later plans had
been in the works for a fifth film that
would have centered on Robin and the
solo hero film might have been a career
breakthrough for O'Donnell but Melvin
and Robin was such a colossal failure
that further plans for the series were
scrapped instead of establishing himself
as a box-office powerhouse O'Donnell
went down with the ship he rejected men
in black in another weirder timeline
audiences are getting jiggy with Chris
O'Donnell instead of Will Smith as the
lead in the hugely popular 1997 hit men
in black but in our reality the former
Robin said no thank you
to a chance at the recurring role
instead Oh Donald virtually disappeared
in the years following the movie's
release perhaps having left Hollywood in
search of a neuralyzer to erase his
memories of passing on the role of agent
Jay whose infinitely cooler than Robin
aniele corpus his comeback also tanked
following a couple of years away from
the industry O'Donnell returned to
action and movies you've probably never
heard of like cookies fortune The
Bachelor and vertical limit
none of them made much of an impact and
Hollywood executives may have viewed
their relative failure as an indication
that O'Donnell's commercial appeal was
damaged beyond repair by those terrible
old bat nipples
the jumped TV with feature opportunities
drying up and a growing family
Oh Donald return to small arcs on shows
like Grey's Anatomy in two and a Half
Men which kept him out of the spotlight
while allowing him to continue working
consistently as an actor Oh Donald
finally found a home on the small screen
with a starring role as the head
crime-fighting orphan on NCIS Los
Angeles so maybe he did get that third
shot at Robin after all family first
ultimately the choice to shy away from
mega fame was O'Donnell's the actor had
been married to his wife Carolyn
Fentress since 1997 and the couple has
five children together O'Donnell said
that he intentionally backed away from
Fame so he could focus on his role as a
father and husband what's next
O'Donnell's career may not be what it
was during the 90s but that doesn't mean
the door is closed he's proven he has
the chops to act in everything from
rom-coms to action films and he's
building a loyal fan base among NCIS Los
Angeles fewer since 2009 it's something
that could translate the box-office gold
give him the right role until then
however he seems content to earn a
steady living while loving the life he's
carved out for himself
and we forgive you for Batman and Robin
I hate to disappoint you but rubber lips
are immune to your charms well we almost
forgive you thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]